bonsoir à toutes et à tous ce soir pour
ce figaro live estivale nous allons
parler des jeux de cartes les plus
iconiques au monde
magic l'assemblée jeu qui a été créée en
93 par un américain et qui a envahi le
monde entier je pense qu'à l'époque
personnes imaginaient le que ça allait
devenir pour parler de ce jeu avec nous
ce soir nous avons marie-amélie la
grande prêtresse des réseaux sociaux du
figaro et charles williams à un joueur
pro et qui sera notre référent et qui
rattrapera le sérieux de cette émission
et on a par ailleurs julien qu'il
s'occupe de notre super real derrière
nous la et simon qui va essayer dans les
différentes chaînes sur lesquelles vous
pouvez commenter tout au long de
l'émission de sélectionner vos questions
nous les relayer etc et je suis très
contente de voir que on a déjà justin
qui nous dit vais-je enfin comprendre
comment on joue à ce genre de jeu
eh ben on va essayer de répondre à
justine et à tous les autres qui seront
là ce soir toutes les réponses arrivent
après le super génériques réalisé par
kevin a tout de suite
[Musique]
bon ben ça commence mais parce que on a
déjà oublié de dire dès le début qu'ils
étaient valentin parce qu'il est très
gentil il présente les autres et c'est
donc valentin est probablement le
journaliste plus multi classe et de
toute cette entreprise donc bon soir
valence rebond soir tous et à tous
donc on va commencer je pense direct
charles
si tu devais résumer magic en quelques
phrases pour le grand public
ça serait quoi bah c'est assez simple
commencé par expliquer comment ça a été
créé magic
en gros l'idée c'était que ce qui est
probable par les créateurs de donjons et
dragons ont ils trouvé ça super cool de
jouer du jeu de rôle et serra de manière
générale et c'était le problème d'une
partie de jeu drôle c'est que c'est très
très long et qu' il faut un set up assez
important et serra et s'est dit comment
est ce qu'on pourrait faire pour jouer à
donjons dragons mais de manière un peu
transportable et si possible en 15
minutes
et du coup magic c'est un peu l'esprit
donjons et dragons mais sur des parties
beaucoup plus courte avec des cartes
utilisent toujours les parties
aujourd'hui
waouh ça peut aller de 5 minutes à une
heure mais le temps moyen c'est quand
même mieux je pense il fait que magic
plus que tous les autres jeux de cartes
parce qu'il ya du très vite des copycat
pourquoi magic c'est celui qui est qui
durent 27 ans déjà et qui a connu ce tel
succès ça il ya plusieurs réponses à
cette question je pense que la première
c'est le fait que les game designers
sont excellents tout simplement ils ont
fait un jeu qui est bien équilibrée qui
inspire en août à des univers quand on a
envie de découvrir tu as l'impression
voilà et les bestiaux qui sont super
balèze a envie de jouer avec et
l'équilibré la richesse du jeu ils ont
réussi à faire un jeu qui puisse être
relativement équilibrée au fur et à
mesure des années et qui propose du
challenge tout le temps en se
renouvelant et je pense aussi le fait
que ce soit le plus vieux ça joue pas
mal parce que du coup ya énormément de
cartes depuis que le jeu est sorti ce
qui permet un nombre de coups de
combinaisons très très élevés et c'est
possible que s'il y avait d'autres
concurrents qui était sorti au même
moment
ne serait pas au même niveau je pense
aujourd'hui comment est ce qu'on m'a dit
qu'à gérer l'arrivée du online parce que
maintenant on a des jeux de cartes qui
sont quasiment exclusivement online
qu'on s'est passé pour magic pas un peu
dans la douleur j'ai envie de dire c'est
à dire qu'ils ont ils ont sorti un soft
qui s'appelle magic online
il ya pas mal d'années le ca s'est
offert au moins dix ans et c'est quelque
chose qui fonctionne mais c'est pas y
perdre user friendly et c'est pas un
truc sur lequel on va apprendre à jouer
quoi ya pas tutoriels et où c'est très
compliqué de savoir comment on s'y
retrouve et du coup ils ont amorcé en
quelque sorte le virage de l'ispor il ya
quelques années en sortant match car
henin qu'elle est là pour le coup un
soft qui se veut très art onlike dans
les visuels et les animations genre de
choses et ça marche assez bien ça a
vraiment explosé en termes de de
visibilité en terme d'histoire et cetera
mais voilà ils peuvent pas mettre toutes
les cartes magic existe depuis et tous
les formats tout parfait du début à la
fin donc c'est en formation quoi c'est
correct
non c'est pas correct pour le coup je
suis joueur compétitive c'est à dire
mince et mes proches à peu près
l'équivalent de un joueur de foot en
deuxième division ça temps en temps je
fais un peu d'argent et c'est cool et
j'aimerais bien monter aux cieux mais on
n'y est pas tout à fait mais on vient
nous aider pas tous jeux qui sont là qui
font ce niveau là pour revenir sur zone
il ya quand même eu une dynamique
positive parce que ça
ça ouvert au grand public ce type de
jeux de cartes de collection bataille
ouais tout à fait en fait l'avantagé
carstens et le fait qu'ils étaient
supportés par blizzard qui est quand
même le plus grand studio de jeux vidéo
au monde
et du coup ils avaient enfin ils ont
énormément de développeurs tout ça et de
gens dont le travail c'est de faire un
board qui soit claire des animations cas
évident
toutes ces choses là et du coup ça a
donné un choc très solide à magic pour
certains arénas savoir on commence par
copier ce qui marche bien et déjà on
sera sûr d'avoir un truc qui sait avec
est plutôt correct ici aujourd'hui à nos
attentes de ceux qui se disent ah bah
tiens j'aimerais commencer magic ok je
sais pas le live du figaro m'a convaincu
sait-on jamais qu'est ce qui fait que
fait cette personne il ya deux
possibilités
celle que moi je trouve la meilleure
c'est de trouver quelqu'un avec qui on a
envie d'apprendre
donc ça peut être un copain ou une
copine un pote quelqu'un qui intéressait
kafui live avec vous et d'aller en
boutique
donc dans toutes les boutiques de jeux
de société en général
il faut au moins un peu du magic et ils
pourront fournir des détails pour
apprendre et en général les les gérants
de boutiques save the magic et du coup
pourront vous expliquer les règles
globalement et si vous avez des
questions pourraient jouer la plupart
des boutiques sont équipés du pas mal de
tables en fête ou qui sont faites dans
ce moment avec le comité pas très
pratique mais de manière générale c'est
quelque chose qu'on peut faire la
deuxième solution celle apprendre via
magic arena du cou qui est le service
qui est gratuit où on peut on peut
télécharger et ils ont refait le
tutoriel récemment il est vraiment pas
mal fait franchement moi j'ai un pote
qui a appris à toi sa copine de zéro à
partir du tutoriel et ça s'est vraiment
bien foutu et ça vous permettra
d'apprendre à jouer à magic assez bien
je pense
si tu commences ans avec des cartes en
physique avec arena tu peux commencer
avec un budget de zéro et si vous
commencez avec des cartes physiques
combien il faut mettre à ton avis pour
eux tu peux commencer à zéro dans l'est
la plupart des boutiques de jeux de
société ont à disposition en partenariat
avec wizard donc est la marque qui vend
magic des packs préconstruits qui sont
des packs d'initiation on étudie voilà
bonjour j'aimerais apprendre à jouer au
magic en général soit c'est sûr des
jours spécifique où il les doit nous
soient ils les ont toujours en continu
parce qu'ils en donnent pas assez à ces
jours-là et du coup il les garde pour la
suite et en fait eu c'est dans leur
intérêt en fait d'oublier ça vous
apprendra chef qui sauf qu'après vous
avez des pensées et comme magic ce n'est
pas le le jeu le plus donné vous allez
probablement finir par dépenser un peu
d'argent
si on fait un petit tour d'horizon
aujourd'hui justement dans la partie
dépenses
qu'est ce qu'on a comme type d'achat
peut être expliquer ce que c'est qu'un
booster expliquer ce que c'est qu'un
quart des préfets et qu'un kit de
construction de bec je pense que c'est
les 3 les trois éléments principaux
ouais alors un booster c'est un peu le
truc de base que vous trouverez donc
dans les boutiques à chaque édition il
change la couleur le nom de l'édition
l'image ci-dessus et cetera le contenu
c'est toujours à peu près le même c'est
15 cartes aléatoires
il y en a dix communes trois communes
une rare ou meetic et en hollande en
venir bien que en toscane avec et du
coup voilà c'est les cartes qui sont
aléatoires et à vous pouvez en avoir des
plus ou moins bien qu'ils rentreront
plus ou moins dans votre deck qui
pourront vous donner des idées pour
créer de nouveaux decks commencé avec ça
c'est pas très pratique c'est en général
quelque chose qu'on achète un peu quand
on a envie de complexifier un peu son
deck ce pas donné pour le coup c'est le
genre entre 3 et 4 euros
c'est en fait c'est plus intéressant en
soi si vous voulez en acheter dans
machete beaucoup sur une boîte parce que
comme il ya de l'aléatoire savalli c'est
aléatoire le fait d'ailleurs aux vocaux
et voudrait plus de chance de trouver ce
que vous cherchez
le deuxième produit tu parlais c'était
le décret construit ça oui j'avais
construit ouais alors ça il y en a
plusieurs types qui sont le coup plus ou
moins compliqués et plus ou moins
difficiles à jouer
ce que vous avez là si je me trompe pas
c'était d'acp l'insolent coeur sont des
cas thème d'isaac à thème ou suivez vous
incarnez un des magiciens en général
volailles à 5 par par éditions xo
monocolore ils sont assez simples et ils
sont bien à prendre en main moi c'est le
produit que je conseille pour les gens
qui pensaient qu'ils commencent à jouer
avec cela est ce que jouer tout à
l'heure des parties de démonstration
ouais ils sont suffisamment compliqué
pour donner envie de jouer au jeu et en
même temps pas trop pour que ce soit pas
la galère niveau plaindrait et ça c'est
assez bien
il ya un autre type de prêt construit
après une fois que vous commencez à
savoir jouer vraiment bien qu'ils
s'appellent les challengers dec ça ils
sortent pas régulièrement ils sont plus
chers c'est au tour de entre 20 et 40
euros
mais cela c'est l'écart tout il ya voilà
il ya les bonnes rare en faut quatre
terrains il ya cds des dettes qui sont
faits à partir de dec mon c'est qu'ils
ont performé pendant la saison et du
coup vous aurez vraiment presque
l'impression de juin des compétitions
enfin si vous savez pas ce que c'est
qu'un des compétitifs vous aurez
vraiment impressionnant juin d'ailleurs
mais voilà c'est aucun peuple construit
et à le kit de construction de digues
dont tu parlais je me trompe pas c'est
un truc avec des landes de l'an et genre
6 où ils booster on peut peut-être
l'ouvrir et en profiter du pour
expliquer les règles de magique au
passage dire c'est quoi les couleurs
c'est quoi le concept de manas je
profite juste moitié de questions au
passage pour que pour les les deux
internautes qui nous impose on a
quelqu'un sur youtube qui demande si on
va jouer à magic un réel ou en digital
bas la partie de ce soir on est parti
pour jouer en réel avec chanceux que
vous êtes ma chance de ce soir je coupe
au hasard dans le dec
ça tombe sur le paintball coeur j'espère
que ça portera bonheur pour tout à
l'heure et puis
on a quelqu'un qui en profitent pour
faire petite fleur à charles et qui dit
la vraie réussite de wizard avec magic
c'est surtout d'avoir donné naissance
aux podcasts dommage
ouais le podcast hommage c'est un pas de
cas ce que je fais avec un pote qui en
du coup on parle toutes les semaines
deux sujets compétitif sur l'évolution
voilà c'est quoi les les compléter la
compétition comment elles se sont
passées et quels sont les différents
développeurs l'évolution des formats en
fait comme il ya beaucoup de cartes si
lé format standard on joue qu'avec les
quatre récents des formats clubs ont
joué les quatre plus vieilles
un peu comme on jouerait ou rugby à xii
au rugby à quinze fois c'est le même jeu
mais pas les mêmes règles et de temps en
temps en interviews des des joueurs de
magic onu qui ont eu des grands
résultats
c'est une dizaine ou une quinzaine
d'interviews des joueurs pros de jackson
et ben vous pouvez taper le poste est à
son image sur google c'est assez facile
à trouver
vous pouvez la voir sur toutes les
applications bobines spotify itunes
normalement si vous cherchez vous
travaillez pas trop pardon je t'en prie
j'ai ouvert la boîte de kits de
construction
donc si on peut profiter pour expliquer
les règles et en même temps donner les
conseils de comment construire un bond
donc index et c'est votre paquet de
cartes de joueurs et il est composé de
60 cartes
voilà je te rend la main alors c'est
assez compliqué de ne rien expliquer
toutes les règles comme ça sans montrer
des cartes mais en gros l'idée c'est
qu'il va y avoir cinq couleurs au magic
donc le blanc le bleu
je suis les fermes en blanc bleu noir
rouge et vert qui vont chacun représenté
différentes valeurs en gros voilà par
exemple blanc ça va être l'ordre et la
loi le noir ça va être plus chez tenait
blaison billets à necromancer genre de
choses les bears avec la forêt les
grosses bêtes ou les petits elfes et
cetera bon je vais faire les cinq ans
même pour les gens ont les rouges
n'avaient les gobelins chez les dragons
c'est plus le feu les dégâts directs
klépierre hommes anciens et en dernier
c'est le bleu c'est la magie de l'esprit
c'est le contrôle de piocher des cartes
de contrecarrer le sort en face
extérieure et du coup d'essai vous allez
devoir poser des créatures pour attaquer
votre adversaire et aidez vos créatures
à vaincre celle de votre adversaire avec
des sorts soit qui vont les tuer soit
qu'ils vont faire grossir vos créatures
soit qu'ils vont faire des choses plus
ou moins compliquées au fur et à mesure
au début pour construire son deck le
plus simple c'est vraiment prendre une
seule couleur pas se poser les questions
de mal à ce que c'est assez compliqué en
gros vous avez deux types de cartes
c'est les terrains et les sorts les
terrains vous permettent de générer du
mal à ce que tu une ressource que vous
pouvez dépenser offert des sorts donc si
tu as déjà joué par stone le manas et
les cristaux qui font à chaque tour à
magic c'est un peu plus compliqué qu'il
faut des terrains et du coup si vous
cherchez pas de terrain vous n'avez pas
de malin et brille pas jouer aux cartes
donc du coup logiquement vous allez
comprendre qu'il va falloir mettre
suffisamment de terrains dans votre deck
pour pouvoir les peluches et puisque
même si vous avez le bon nombre de
terrains mathématiquement en pratique il
suffit que vous n'avez pas de chance
pour que vont ils pas assez donc c'est
quelque chose qui va falloir penser
normalement si je me trompe pas dans
l'équipe de construction dès qu il doit
y avoir un petit papier qui explique
tous ces choses-là basique qui va vous
dire à peu près combien de terrain il
vous faut comme une créature tu peux me
contredira valentin situe al-badri
soulagé on a on a bien on a bien un
guide qui rappelle donc les principes
associés à chaque couleur la pondération
importante quand on crée comment
invoquer une carte comment utiliser une
carte là ici on a la pondération il qui
vendent des manières leur le ratio en
fait on revient à une idée de coût
global où on se dit si j'ai trop de
cartes qui valait cher ça risque d'être
compliqué parce que le temps que j'ai
suffisamment de mana de magie pour
pouvoir les invoquer
risque de me faire attaquer par plein de
petites créatures et où je je serais
mort avant tout à faire tu peux
commencer par regarder les cartes
est ce qu'il ya des règles importantes à
prendre en compte justement pas plus de
x carte très cher à avoir au moins entre
10 et 20 perd 1 pour pour un dec pour un
chèque de 60 car ça va être plutôt entre
20 et 30
est ce pour un mec de 40 cartes où tu
vas être autour de 17 terrains en
général si l'on doit donner des chiffres
qui sont un chiffre ou vous avez besoin
de vous poser des questions sur 60 c'est
au tour de 24 d'entre eux 22 27 en
fonction de ce qu'ils ont grossi votre
deck est très agressif qui a plein de
créatures pas cher il a pas besoin
d'avoir énormément de terrain parce
qu'au bout d'un moment vous allez avoir
cinq six sept terrains sur le bord des
cartes et coûte entre 1 et 3 ça sert à
rien inversement si votre deck c'est un
acte qui est plus lourd c'est à dire
qu'il va jouer des sorts chères qui font
beaucoup de choses falloir qu'il ait
plus de terrain parce que voilà si vous
avez trois cartes à 600 mhz un exacto
cinq terrains vous ne pouvez rien faire
sur facebook où on peut avoir un chèque
de plus de 100 cartes ça se peut ça un
des cas plus de 100 quartier des modes
de jeu dans lequel satisfait oui alors
il ya un mode de jeu qui s'appelle le
commandeur où les gens jouent à 100
cartes qui est un mode de jeu qui est
assez populaire c'est possible que ce
soit ça a quel effet référence
en gros l'idée c'est qu'on a une carte
de chaque exemplaire dans son deck et un
commandant à côté et du coup c'est tout
bon souvent et des cas thème autour du
commandant et sinon il ya certaines
cartes dans votre deck en gros on est
obligé de jouer minimum 60 cartes mais
on peut en jouer plus en général c'est
pas bien dangereux plus parce que plus
vous mettez de cartes dans votre deck
moins vous avez de chances de piocher
vos meilleures cartes mais il ya
certaines cartes par exemple qu'ils
disent
au début de votre tour si vous avez plus
de 200 cartes dans votre déco gagné la
partie
et bah du coup ça regardez des façons de
construire au dec un peu différente tout
à l'heure sur twitter j'ai eu pas mal de
commentaires qui me disait ah on va
ressortir les histoires de bec lotus qui
valent très cher et on a vu qu'un petit
peu avant est ce que tu viens de nous
parler de de ce grand mythe du black
lotus
il nous dira aussi si des cartes
aujourd'hui j'ouvre un booster est ce
que je pouvais espérer avoir une carte
très cher alors j'imagine d'or québec
lotus pas mais voilà quelle est la carte
la plus rare et la plus chère que je
pouvais espérer et piocher en ouvrant un
booster alors du coup pour la croix la
question qu'est ce que c'est que le
black le tueur c'est un peu la carte
emblématique de magic sa carte la plus
chère en fait qui sortit depuis la halle
à la première édition
et voilà régulièrement et c'est très
très dur à trouver en fait si vous en
avez un bon état présente sa 80 ou 100
mille euros un truc comme ça s'était
pris une bagnole grand bal en plus donc
c'est c'est quelque chose voilà donc
deux collections et serra on se demande
tous voilà qui dépenseraient autant pour
pour un bout de carton et puis on vous
dit ça avant jusqu'aux on achète une
carte à dix euros sinon j'ai une carte à
25 euros puis 50 à 100 et un jour on se
retrouve à avoir des trucs de collations
chez toi et on sait pas comment sait pas
comment ça s'est passé un peu ça qu'est
ce que tu as chez toi pas pour inviter
les cambrioleurs mais pas forcément la
plus chère mais celle où tu t'es dit
voilà celle là c'est cema fétiche je la
garderai toujours nagé des cartes
j'ai des cartes cher pour le coût genre
par exemple des berceaux de gaia les
trucs à peu près de 100 balles pillage
pense et j'étais des mers souterraine
cdd vieux bilan dans fait des cartes de
la première édition ça va parler aux
initiés mais pas trop c'est un peu
paradoxal que ce soit était un qui
valent plus cher mais en gros si vous
avez un terrain qui fait de couleurs
différentes
ben c'est super pratique quand vous avez
un deck bicolore et pesant d'avoir une
île où une montagne fait à la fois du
matin bleu et du moulin rouge et ça ça
coûte plusieurs centaines d'euros
et quand vous voulez jouer dans les
vieux formats par exemple à voir donc
moi personnellement je suis pas un grand
partisan de l'idée que les cartes magic
ça doit coûter cher mais comme il ya eu
une forme de d'économie autour de ça qui
c'est qui s'est construite
oui ça ne peut plus vraiment réimprimer
ces cartes sans attaquer la confiance
des utilisateurs et du coup on se
retrouve dans les formats qui ont un peu
bloqué par l'argent ce que je trouve un
peu dommage
la foulée de ces cartes très cher il
disait sur twitter j'ai entendu
l'histoire
d'un tournoi légendaire à nantes on
pouvait gagner 1000 ma nation déchirée
un black lotus est ce que tu sais si
c'est une légende urbaine l'outil c'est
un vrai truc ça ressemble pas mal à une
légende urbaine des cartes qui doivent
se déchirer il ya extrêmement peu et
c'est sur des éditions spécifiques qui
sont les cartes pour le fun en fait que
magic fait de temps en temps donc je je
ne vois pas à quoi ça peut faire
référence mais il est possible que je
suis né en 95 donc peut-être qu'il
savait des choses à l'époque j'étais pas
au courant et des règles qui étaient
rajouter au tournoi je ne sais pas
pour la deuxième partie de la question
d'ailleurs que j'ai parlé à jour il
répond tout à l'heure si on pouvait
ouvrir des cartes de nos jours très cher
dans un booster vous aurez rarement une
carte qui vaut plus de 40 ou 50 euros
mais c'est toujours plaisir de voir une
différence entre magic pc et jeux de
société
ce que je sais même pas quel jeu de
société magic bon je sais pas s'il parle
du jeu de société ou s'il parle du jeu
de cartes
je crois qu'il ya un jeu de société mais
j'ai jamais joué donc je sais pas
exactement ce qu'il vaut moi je trouve
que le jeu de cartes c'est beaucoup plus
sympa parce qu'on a ces droits sont à
couper un petit peu charles petit
problème technique on va on va meubler
un métier de retrouver chez elle en
attendant donc je pense que ce que
charles voulais dire c'est le côté
humain du jeu de voir son adversaire se
dé confire camp quand on le tue en
direct et c'est ce que vous verrez tout
à l'heure quand marc et amélie me mettre
à mal ou quand elle aura pas assez de
manac j'en profiterai pour l'attaqué
avec metrol ça pourrait donner sa vraie
c'est magic l'assemblée
c'est à dire quand en ce moment avec le
virus il ya plus de tous les tourments
papiers ont été annulés pour 2020 et on
ne sait même pas si elle aura pour 2021
et moi je sais que pas moi ça me manque
beaucoup de voir tous mes amis que j'ai
l'habitude de voir en tournoi et il ya
beaucoup de gens qui descendent en fait
on joue tous online d'ailleurs nos ordis
mais c'est un peu tripes et les reprises
des tournois et il ya des dettes privées
ou pas encore on sait pas c'est possible
qu'il y en a des bus 2021 mais on sait
pas vraiment à quoi s'attendre
la marque veut pas s'engager donc en
attendant
ce qu'on commence une partie
démonstration pour expliquer les règles
du goût pas y aller le droit de 210 à
chaque fois je vais pas vous entendiez
je vais nous rejoindre gentiment
exactement et je vais me forcer à ne pas
regarder le chat pour tous ceux qui me
diront et aux fêtes valentin ça ne
l'était pas trop parce que vous vous
allez voir mon jeu grâce au super c
set-up mis en place par julien abelli
mon canton quand on commence comme tout
jeu de cartes
on coupe le dec la coupe se fait
toujours vers le joueur qui ramasse son
fils à magic on retourne la carte qu'on
coupe pour montrer le coup qui se trouve
en haut à droite de la carte donc c'est
le coût d'un vocation la valeur en magie
de la carte donc la marée mis une valeur
en magie de deux étoiles 3 et moi de 3
donc c'est moi qui vais commencer sur
cette partie alors ça c'est une légende
qui faisait comme 2ème dan et je sais ce
que j'ai fait aussi la première fois
j'ai appris un jeu magic on m'a montré
sa et serra de le genre on l'entendait
c'est pas mal plus simple les avides de
révélations en cascade dans l'index
on n'a pas pris de vous avait révélé des
as à côté de votre terrain je crois à
côté du tapis où il ya plein de dès
qu'ils ont été laissés là par les
rôlistes à mon avis non c'est pas d'idée
c'est pas dit c'est ok c'est des petites
des petites au caire effectivement c'est
mes vielles tocane magic on a rangé les
gars du coup on part à cette carte
chacun au premier tour et le joueur qui
commence ne piège pas on est bien
d'accord qu'il a quand même un avantage
non négligeable le fait de commencer
c'est assez fort donc il ya une action
qui s'appelle le milligan si on n'a
aucun terrain dans sa carte au premier
tour quand on commence la partie on a le
droit de remettre angers le jeu et deux
reprises reproché cette carte c'est
presque ça en gros c'est des cons à une
main qu'on estime que pas assez bien
qu'en général quand on a pas terrain
mais ça peut être quand on n'a qu'un
seul terrain où quand on a que désire un
faucon pas la cause et carte qui coûte 6
en main par exemple on pourra rien faire
avant tours 6 on peut re mélanger notre
main dans l'index et on reprend 2,7 et
ensuite il faudra par contre remettre
une carte de notre main en dessous et
c'est un peu le faire autant de fois
qu'on veut mais à chaque fois il faut
remettre une carte de plus lieu d'être
gardons une carte une carte une carte de
ton choix de ta main ok voilà des mains
qu'ils gardent donc je pense que n'aura
pas ça pour le moment
il ya des phases de jeu le premier tour
il n'y a pas de phase d'entretien
donc on va commencer par poser on a
droit de poser un terrain maximum par
tour souhaitable et des cartes qu'on va
pouvoir spécial qui permettent de faire
autre chose donc moi je vais poser une
montagne est la lanterne rouge donc pas
ce que je veux me rouge et donc la
couleur la couleur du rouge c'est la
couleur rouge
les paires associés aux rouges sont les
montagnes et je n'ai rien d'autre à
faire
avec mon dec en tout cas pas pour
l'instant
et donc je vais dire fin du coup pareil
pas de dégagement pas d'entretien et
l'europe cherché non du coup pareil
bastia pioche
c'est comme ça que je suis qui commence
qui fait manquer sa poupée moi je joue
vers donc j'ai des forêts et je pose une
forêt est pareil fin de tout repos ok
donc là je pioche une carte hop je peux
aussi benzia une deuxième montagne et là
je vais pouvoir commencer à faire
quelque chose je vais invoqué une
créature donc j'engage donc le fait de
tourner deux mètres à l'horizontale ou
de changer l'angle des cartes digal sont
engagés ça veut dire qu'on les a
utilisés parce que la majorité des
cartes ne peuvent être utilisé qu'une
seule fois par tour et donc j'invoque un
transporteur de braise qui est un petit
gobelins et vous voyez en bas à droite
de la carte
il y à un chiffre à gauche et un chiffre
à droite le chiffre à gauche c ca
poussan sa puissance d'attac
le chiffre à droite c'est son endurance
donc sa défense donc là il a 2 2 ça veut
dire qu'il peut faire de dégâts et qui
survit jusqu'à de dégâts c'est à dire
que si il perd un point de vie il est
encore vivant mais s'il perd 2 himeur la
spécificité c'est que son endurance
remonte remonte à la fin de chaque tour
en cours c'est à dire que si on lui met
un dégât dans le tour bien des gars au
tour suivant ça ne l'a pas le cul voilà
et sur la carte il y à une description
de la compétence spécifique de cette
carte
donc le mien à un petit un gris ce qui
veut dire qu en fait peu importe la
couleur du mana si je paye 1 et que je
le sacrifie en fait il pose sa bombe
et si fait de dégâts à la cible de mon
choix d'une cible ça peut être une
créature ou un joueur ça peut être un
plein soleil car si on verra ça plus
tard si vous en avez voilà mais là j'ai
plus de mana donc je veux pas le faire
parce que j'ai pas d'intérêt à sacrifier
ma créatures pour l'instant et au
premier camp la créature vient d'être
invoquée est là ce qu'on appelle le mâle
d'invocation qui fait qu'il ne peut pas
être utilisé tout de suite
elle vient d'arriver là-bas voilà le
tour c'est le
le petit chemin de la ta ta ta ta ta ta
mais voilà donc je dis fin et entrepôts
ya une question sur facebook dame atria
qui nous manque c'est vrai qu'une série
netflix magic qui en préparation est ce
que quelqu'un a des infos là dessus
voilà c'est tout à fait vrai mais par
contre ça fait longtemps qu'on n'a pas
eu d'information de c'est donc on nous a
dit que c'était le cas on nous avait
parlé de peut-être des gens qu'il ferait
dans le casting mais au final pas plus
donnée aux cas ça pour le moment
historique castrés qui je sais plus
j'avais j'avais vu les noms des gens
mais après ça j'ai oublié d aucuns 62
googlé dans les dents les viewer est de
mettre un petit bien ou une petite info
sur les tchats je veux bien je joue un
rôle au des corses de caillou avec un
marqueur sur les près de 3,3 et si je
les enlève son marqueur il ne peut plus
être la cible de sorts votre capacité
des adversaires jusqu'à jusqu'à la fin
du tour et donc du coup une question de
mois le fait d'enlever un marqueur ça
peut être fait n'importe quand c'est une
caste est activée ça peut être activée
n'importe quand même pendant ton tour
surtout pas dans ton tour en général et
ça peut même être fait en réponse à ce
qu'on appelle en réponse à un sort aux
critères que si toi tu essayes de
griller son son troll ce qui pourrait
être une stratégie gagnante et kehl
allemagne à 10 payables peu en réponse
activisme 3d le protéger et ses toiles
sur la ctgc que sur un sort qui la cible
oui sauf que c'est un sport où les
capacités de capacité à garder son nom
il ya simon notre formidable cm qui nous
montre de l'info et qui dit que without
growth travaille sur une future série
animée autour des cartes magic aux
commandes de la fiction les frères russo
réalisateur des dernières film avengers
pour marvel ah oui c'est vrai j'avais lu
ça et banon
comme je suis rouge je suis forcément
agressif
1 le feu la braise
challenge ardent et donc ja pâques
marie-amélie bloqué avec mon troll que
j'ai pas particulièrement envie de
perdre pour l'instant et du coup je vais
garder bien pour moi et je vais encaissé
les deux digues à la fois quand même
visualiser le fait que tu est attaqué
par un petit gobelins 2-2 et ton troll
et 3 3 sauf que tu t'en ciellement je
pourrais juillet de 1 pour faire un des
gars en plus aigus pas envie non parce
qu'en fait si le sacrifice en gobelin
sont vos l'un d'eux pourra pas infliger
de dégâts la tacc puisqu'il sera mort au
moment des dégâts à temps il a ok donc
en gros tu es en gros il est possible
que light représente le fait qu'il a une
carte qui pourra jouer dans le combat
oui qu'il rendrait sentais bien plus
fort et toi à partir de ce moment là tu
peux soit accepter le fait qu' il peut
jouer sa carte est saturé la tienne oui
et c'est pas forcément grave
ou alors si c'est grave tu tu considères
que tu après 13 en vigueur dès ton troll
est une prend pas de risques mais c'est
possible aussi que ce soit un bluff
total et qu'il ait rien du tout c'est
possible seuls les spectateurs qui
voient mon jeu ça aussi je bluffe pas
mais je blokhine je vais les prendre
donc voilà donc au départ on commence
avec 20 points de vie chaque joueur et
si je ne m'abuse ou en tout cas à
l'époque il ya 15 ans mais du coup si on
peut jouer avec des mecs joueur incarne
ça peut-être changé il y avait deux
façons de gagner une partie soit enlevé
tous les points de vie de l'adversaire
soit lui faire défaut c'est toutes ces
cartes quand il avait plus de cartes à
piocher
du coup il pouvait de fait de fait plus
jouer et donc ils perdaient parce que
c'est encore comme ça il ya beaucoup de
règles qui ont été rajoutés mais en gros
c'est vrai qu'ils savent que tant qu'on
peut si on ne peut pas piocher dans son
index acsi on doit piocher avec notre
des quais vides on perd la partie
instantanément et pareil si on descend à
0.2 vie on perd la partie
après s'il ya des cartes qui disent vous
ne pouvez pas perdre c'est avant tout
les choses très compliquées forcément
voilà donc fin et la marie amélie tu as
18 points de vie est moins 20
alors
j'ai mes gars qui se casse et aux
islettes et du coup je vais jouer une
morsure enragé pour faire un nombre de
dégâts et galamaz créatures sur la
sienne la force de la créature sur la
sienne du coup j'ai ce que je peux faire
un sacrifice
absolument c'est à dire que la fonction
la façon dont fonctionnent les effets à
magic donc sous une forme de piles c'est
à dire que vous avez empilait les effets
les uns sur les autres et le dernier à
avoir été activée se résoudra en premier
attends ça fait combien la régal à la
force de ma créatures nos mémoires
salaire 3 pour le moment ouais et des
3,3 donc elle fait trois dégâts sur les
tons truc c'est ballot étoiles et 3,3 du
coup le bas je sacrifie pour te faire
deux points de riga toi et coutumes
passait 16 16 et je t'attaque donc je
passe à 17 ans avant une partie très
serrée
nous sommes mais entre ces deux partis
n'est ce pas en plus c'est terrible
parce que j'ai longtemps et moi on est
on a tous les deux joué à magic ya genre
alors je comptais pour moi ça doit faire
à peu près 15 ans ah oui et toi valentin
oued ont tendance à tendre la et donc ça
à peu près à l'époque où moi j'ai
commencé à jouer et un hommage et un
élément taj gray cheveux qui est une 3 3
qui à chaque fois qu'un adversaire subi
des blessures non combat donc si je lui
envoie une boule de feu peu importe mais
qui ne papa papa provoquée par une
créature directement en mordant en
attaque quand elle gagne +1 + 0 jusqu'à
la fin du tour voilà je m'arrête là
j'ai l'impression qu'on va avoir un
scénario déjà vu brûler morsure alors au
troll est très vert très féroce juste du
coup j'en profite pour dire on a droit
jusqu'à quatre exemplaires de la même
carte
en dehors des terrains et de certaines
cartes spécifiques comme notamment le
plein volcker on a droit d'en avoir
qu'un seul dans 12 des cas alors c'est
pas tout à fait vrai une presse croquer
en dehors des terrains
à 15 ans il épate mais un seul coeur ça
ne pouvait pas être drôle et non les
terrains de base on peut mais d'en
revendre les terrains différents peut
avoir que 4,6 et les pinceaux le cas on
peut en avoir quatre pareil cas pareils
ok juste qu'il faut les avoir du bon
sens général qui m'est chère à invoquer
donc n'oubliez pas on revient avec le
coût de leur vocation
pourquoi il donc à damas avec 3 soit
leur garde
yann bellec place walker qui choqua
déplaise à l'occasion du mapaq
esthétique très bien alors qu'il ya une
application gratuite fournie par magic
qui permet de de tenir le compte des
points de vie
on peut choisir la couleur des joueurs
et bon coup avec le plus ou moins on
fait donc là on est à 16 14
vous pouvez laisser visé affiché sur
l'écran ce sera pas mal pour les joueurs
comme ça si ça me déprime le malade
c'est vrai qu'à l'heure un peu plus et
ça serait par un jugement très bon comme
ça vous pourrez avoir plus de place et
un terrain comme ça ça marche pour toi
cinq terrains très bien un gros mensonge
et pour 5 malin non ces marins
non mais moi aussi j'ai la même carte
donc je remets l'élément talent gré
cheveux l'a33 et jeudi fin
j'attaque
je bloque hockey qui est une 3 3 et je
profite de mon dernier manas pour la
faire passer en fait à 6,5 et donc elle
ne meurt pas et comme le sort et pour ma
créatures et par un sort contre la
tienne tu ne peux pas utiliser le sac
que tu peux lire ton était petit on ne
peut pas le voir à l'écran la barbade la
créature ciblé gagne plus 3 en attaque
et +2 en défense jusqu'à la fin du tour
et au milieu de la carte juste au dessus
de du texte il ya écrit éphémère
éphémère ça veut dire que c'est un sort
qu'on peut lancer à peu près quand on
veut jouer contre nous alors simplifiée
et là du coup tu n'as pas les effets à
marie amélie pour sauver sa créature la
petite salle est donc décédé
je t'aimais bien écoute il a mangé de
personnes s'étaient déjà pas mal je pose
une forêt et pour 5 je pose un élan
était réduite 3 piétinement et qui me
permet d'aller chercher le pianiste
walker alors il paraît comme on est sur
du gard où il faut parler un bon
français donc j'ai cru comprendre que la
traduction était arpenteurs donc c'était
un beau des vestiaires panther puis ils
ont abandonné maintenant il utilise
pétrole quand même en français en fait
c'est ce sont des magiciens qui passe
d'univers parallèles enfin d'un plan de
la réalité à un autre plan de la réalité
comme d'un challenge c'est bien ça ouais
c'est ma c'est un peu comme doctor
strange et j'allais dire que si vous
lisez des mangas c'est un peu comme
plein de vie ces cailloux les gens se
réincarne dans un univers de fantasy ou
autre et ben voilà avec des pouvoirs un
peu de shit et donc ça peut arriver
oublie pas de mélange et honda qu après
être allé sur ces bris ça c'est pas vu à
l'écran donc je sais pas je dis ça au
cas où tu oublie pas ses mots c'est fini
hop
et du coup on peut en profiter pour
expliquer ce que c'est le piétinement
pas sa créature est une 3 3 qui est
tellement ça que lorsque on affiche des
blessures de combat lorsque les
créatures se battre si là il a une 3 3
valentin ces braquages trois jeux voilà
donc si elle se bat
elles vont mourir tout les 2 ans combat
mais si tu attaques et la créature de
valentin titre une 2 2 comme le gobelin
tout à l'heure et qui bloque avec le
piétinement ça permet d'archiver les
dégâts restant sur ses points de vue du
coup c'est utile sur des grosses
créatures
là je fais un sort donc non au temps
pour moi je ne fais pas de sport je vais
mal compté 6-4 6-6 pardon donc 4-1
dernière ou d' outrage de chandra qui
fait quatre blessures à la créature
cible est donc forcément je cible c'est
là et qui de plus fait deux blessures au
contrôleur de la créature ce qui fait
passer ma carte à 4,3 pendant ce tour
parce que à chaque fois qu'un adversaire
subi des blessures non combat et là
c'était une blessure non combat les
créatures que vous contrôlez c'est
toutes les créatures gagne +1 + 0
jusqu'à la fin du tour et j'attaque avec
une adresse berne ouais ton derniere
autres à le rejoindre il s'est juste
rien à voir avec ce qu'on a
c'était juste pour rien et chine je vois
pas très bien où il fait le fait 4 en en
coûts d'invocation 6e actuellement des
voies non c'était juste et dont nous
interdire quatre points de vie plus donc
je reviens en tête et voilà merci de
votre soutien at à moins de cartes en
main tu sais pas ce qui va t'arriver
un petit crocodile de vivien qui gagne
plus un plus un si je viens ou vivienne
vivien sur la table qui est le nom du
plein volcker de soleil voilà et c'est à
ton tour
hop c'est combien combien de base se
croyait 3 3 c'est bien ce match bien la
créature de valentin c'est pour le coup
c'est pas une partie très équilibrée en
a fait on a fait pire sur les parties
d'échauffement et donc c'est bien sûr
aussi j'invoque un élément talent
pyroclastiques qui est une créature 5 4
donc je devrais re déséquilibre le jeu
et qui a comme capacité sans engagement
à chaque fois que je paye 3 mana 1-1
colorent de rouge de faire une boule de
feu est donc une blessure aux joueurs
ciblés ce qui est très bien en
combinaison avec l'élément talent gré
cheveux parce que si je fais une
blessure
l'élément talent passera 4 3 et lui-même
passera à 6 4 ça c'est une capacité
active et du coup tu peut déclencher
quand tu veux au même moment tu pourras
jouer avec les maires c'est ça
sauf que là j'ai plus de mana donc je
vais pas pouvoir la déclencher tout de
suite et je vais pas attaquer avec mon
élémentale gré cheveux parce que marie
amélie pourrait bloquer or remarque si
je suppose que si elle bloque après mon
empire au plastique passe passe
tranquillement
bravo je vais attaquer parce que je suis
en bois et en plus tu as intérêt à
attaquer aussi puisqu'elle ta révéler
n'y viennent le tour avant et que si tu
as lu le texte de la carte vivienne
booste les créatures sur le terrain et
du coup elle a intérêt à avoir une
créature 61 et du coup la cl ce trade
est moins favorable pour elle dans cette
situation c'est ce que j'ai pas trop
envie de trade
je mets un cycle de croissance dessus
pour la booster straub strache la fin du
tout très bien mais comme ça tu auras
pas mon pyroclastiques
que tu crois et bien joué en tout cas et
c'est bien en palettes donc sais pas si
vous vous souvenez du film podium et
j'avais envie de dire je choisis la
formule offensive s'est pas vu le film
mais je ne vois que la situation est en
train de tourner au désavantage fait
attention
ah oui à la le plein munger mon
crocodile passe à 4 4 et attend est-ce
qu'il ya non illyriennes m comme
marqueur particulier sur la gelée encore
jamais joué je t'avoue alors pour mettre
un ingénieur pour mettre un des tubes
pour marquer le nombre de compteurs cas
là tu m'as tu peux mettre un nombre de
trucs égal et du coup le principe de
plaies sur le corps c'est que c'est un
permanent que tu que tu poses et que tu
peux utiliser chaque tour je fais des
effets clottu peut la lire son premier
réflexe et je cible une créature et je
mets trois marqueurs plus simple
ceinture elle si je retire un de ces
marqueurs si tu rajoutes en fait si je
le rajoute un si jeune dans l'es20 en
revanche je rêvais de les cartes de la
bibliothèque jusqu'à ce que je révèle
une carte de créatures jeu mais cette
gare dans la main il reste au dessous de
la bibliothèque dans un ordre aléatoire
et en retirant six la créature ciblé
gagne + 10 + 10 et acquièrent de
piétinement jusqu'à la fin du tour
quand on voudrait qu'ils ont des gros
pouvoir
on était sérieux c'est vraiment pouvoir
mais pour ça il faut avoir jusqu'à six
marqueurs est donc pour l'instant elle
en a que 3 oui d'accord que la première
capacité jeu peut l'activer
tout à fait tu vois là et je peux
l'utiliser qu'une seule de ses capacités
par tour oui et du tabac je vais juste a
ajouté un sur elle je vais prendre du
verre parce que parce que hertz et je
vais et booster un peu le croco la tête
parce que j'ai encore un peu de vert oui
le truc que tu as mis sur le croco c'est
pour signifier le fait qu'il est plus
simple à 0 qu'ils apprécient de plus en
plus important jeu d'accord alors je
sors faire attention à pas confondre les
marqueurs et l'effet qu'il y ait ce donc
on va faire comme ça font pas et je la
mets de deux couleurs différentes aux
journaux critiques du coup elle est
combien 3 4 5 6 7 à les 3 4 5 6 7 7bis
elle assez grosse maj dans la ssi
valentin déjà classé prendre sa décision
et ensuite je ferme mon commentaire oui
parce que oui si valentin de quoi
booster à mort son truc c'est moi qui
morfleraient déjà sous mes terrains sont
engagés donc je peux pas faire grand
chose et en plus elle a le piétinement
donc de toute façon j'ai bâti mon ses
lacets lecerf qui a effectivement donc
j'ai envie dire que
euh compliqué et
en voilà deux types de décisions soit tu
bloques est à créature marc gratos ça tu
bloques pas et tu concept ce qui est
propre représentent la moitié de tp
ouais je vais tenter de miser sur le
fait de piocher une bonne carte et donc
perdre 7 points de vie ouais moi je
pense que c'est la bonne décision à ce
niveau là parce que c'est parce que
ouais là si tu as fait un seul a bloqué
de toute façon au tour d'après je me
ferais attaqué je le perdrai et j'aurai
plus de créatures alors que là je peux
potentiellement récupérer une carte qui
me permettrait de bloquer tout en
gardant cette créature vivante et de
reprendre potentiellement un ascendant
quoi il ya un autre truc aussi que peut
faire c'est bloqué avec une carte va
piocher une carte qui sera moins bien et
du coup tu pourras sacrifiant bloc et
utiliser la carte coda sur le terrain
pour tuer la libyenne qui était vrai ce
qui a été laissé sans défense sur table
c'est vrai tout à fait parce qu'elle a
que quatre points de vie et comme j'ai 5
en attaque je peux la tuer mais ça reste
assez risqué aussi commencé à 6,6 et non
pas 7 7 et donc je vais exactement à
suivre les conseils du professionnel est
ce que je suis une pause pour deux
questions qui entre deux enfin une
question avec une réponse quelqu'un de
10 par rapport aux compétitions cnbb 8
qui dit par rapport aux compétitions
qu'il est le pays le plus représenté
pour le jeu et maximilien lui dise et
les états unis
est-ce que c'est correct ouais ces
accords avec les trois pays pleure et
pointé sont les états unis puis au japon
depuis la france on a quand même une
bonne baisse de joueurs en france
ouais enfin trois joueurs plongés dans
la carte en japonais un soul d'ayo tient
et une foudre quand elles arrivent en
jeu tu dois y lire en japonais
non parce que du coup je connais leurs
effets donc je vais suivre les conseils
de charles est invoqué un petit crash
feu de chandra une créature 1 3 qui a le
vol alors le vol ça veut dire que donc
elle n'est pas au sol logique
et donc que les créatures qui n'ont pas
le vol ne peuvent pas la bloquer si je
décide
d'attaqué avec mais je vais l'utiliser
en sacrifice pour pour bloquer
effectivement mon élémentale
pyroclastiques va attaquer le marcheur
de plaine il mourra au passage mais y
tue le marcheur de plaine ce qui
descendra fortement la la vie du lait à
la puissance du crocodile
si tu peux excellent terme planeswalker
pascal marcheurs de plaine pour le coup
ouais pardon je dis n'importe quoi je
suis jeune j'ai pas ce qu'on s'est
entraîné pendant deux semaines avec marc
ml avec le mauvais termes et du coup bah
vous dire arpenteurs quand les gens
connaissent arpente avoir panther à la
limite au fait en tout cas sur la
communication ça a été super g et un
accent très très pourri voilà et donc
fin et donc je retire mon marqueur du
crocodile puisque ea personnes plus un
plus un qui n'était valable que quand
les l'autre c'est un marqueur permanent
les quelques commentaires à l'e3 donc
c'est quand même une 6 6 et 7
c'est bon
alors
ma des angles caméra de rouge du pioch
ta carte et attendre dix mois jusqu il
fait honte au bas des faits on sent
enfin rien d'intéressant
son but c'est de la sacrifier pour
bloquer une de tes attaques quoi du coup
j'ai tech je bloque
si t'as pas debout ce qui donne le
piétinement elmer et je suis revenu un
tour de plus les tiennent oui elles
tiennent leur oui juste pourquoi ton 5,4
et mort le célèbre n 5 car à mon 5,4 c e
quand j'ai attaqué le plein bogard ici
c'est pas donné à l'otan pour moi non
loin de là plus haut qu'un seul car il
est donc je bloque
l'embellie est engagée parce que
j'attaquais donc je blogue je sacrifie
le chandra et voilà merci beaucoup
j'avais j'étais pas attentifs à ce
moment là je lisais le chat est
quelqu'un a dit pourquoi ton plus ta
carte est morte et du cou merci merci le
tchad le tchad joue avec valentin 1 de
tous et je joue un élément tel celui qui
peut me transformer transformer des
terrains en créature 5,5 célérité
célérité ça veut dire que ça peut
attaquer claqué tout de suite excellent
jeu voilà ça leur change ma vocation
il est combien convient de bien se
trouver 5,5 plutôt puissant
situation devient précaire pour pas
longtemps ça redevient précaire donc
malheureusement je n'ai pas piocher de
terrain donc je peut invoquer qu'un
élément telle grée cheveux celui qu'on a
déjà vu deux fois
qui donc qui est une 3 3 et à chaque
fois qu'un adversaire subi des dégâts
donc par exemple si j'utilisais
l'élément pyroclastiques pour lancer des
boules de feu
toutes les créatures passe aurait plus
un plus un malheureusement bas je ne
peux pas donc je vais garder mes
créatures en défense et dire fin le fait
que tu puisses acquis les 50 us et à ses
pratiques parce que du coup je peux le
faire en attaque aussi bien qu'en
défense
voilà sauf que je crains d'avoir
démocratie et de mana tu peux pas le
faire tout de suite mais
hypothétiquement 5 à toi à toi marie
mini les joueurs voient mon jeu et
voient que j'avais des supers carte
si j'avais eu quelques terrains
malamine ils piègent pas trop malin pour
le coup je crois c'est du pillage pas
trop mal tiens on nous dit éco
chaussures et cochons tiens c'est mignon
comme ses doigts sur tweets qui nous dit
est-ce qu'on peut te croiser lors du
tournoi sur paris charles voilà le
général dé kia b tournant avec un peu
dangereux sur pareil je me déplace et
c'était parti après il ya beaucoup de
tournois qui sont assez petits ducs on
peut pas être tous heureusement moi je
vais dire que trois 3 5 4
de 4,5
je tape je fais un dégage un terrain
ciblé que je contrôle genre celui là je
lui mets un token dessus pourquoi on
fasse la différence et c'est une 5,5
célérité et du coup tout ce qui se passe
il faut que je fasse bien mais contre je
me reprenne le retour de bâton mais
normalement avec celle là je peux
attaquer tranquille tu es obligé de
bloquer temps faut maintenant c'est là
où il faut que je réfléchisse c'est là
bas que j'ai vécu je sacrifier mon
alimentaires gras cheveux origines sont
tout à fait claires mais par contre si
j'attaque avec les trois tu peux bloquer
de le et en a une il est de 3 et si tu
bloques site en bloc 2 je vais donc avec
mon élément talent je blogue celui là
pour éviter que marie-mai 10 générer
d'autres d'autres et puis voilà je
bloque le plus puissant pour seulement
perdre seulement entre 5 et 6 le voilà
donc je suis là deux points de vie voilà
comme vous aviez pas beaucoup de manhaé
pas d'effet sap a changé grand chose
mais normalement tu va annoncer tout et
bloqueur à vendre de réseaux de les
dégâts parce qu'en gros si tu as un sort
qui booste et créatures ça n'aurait pas
été clair métallisé du bloc une créature
puis je la bouche puis je l'appuie elmer
puisque blake avec les autres acteurs
donc celui qui dit je déclare truc truc
truquant bloqueurs c'est ça je dis lui
le plus beau le plus les blocs lui est
en fait tu fais des effets qu'il est
ouest ou bombages invoque un petit
gobelins qui ne me suffira pas survivre
mais l'évasion de tango et je pense que
je vais mourir dans à peu près 30
secondes donc fera donc tout le loisir
de demander à charles
de la part toujours de cochon qui est
motivé si tu as un avis sur justement
l'édition 2022 manière globale et sur
les postes et les boosters jump start
moi j'étais assez assez agréablement
surpris par l'édition 2022 parce qu'en
général les échos recettes comme ils
s'appellent scellier les éditions avec
des années en général c 17 qui sont
plutôt fait pour les débutants et
général pour les joueurs expérimentés on
a vite fait le tour et celui ci je le
trouvais assez sympa j'ai pas mal
fonctionné je suis plutôt content voilà
si vous avez l'occasion de jouer en
draft dans vos boutiques je vous
conseille de la draft et m21 trouve très
sympa les boosters james startt c'est un
nouveau truc dont j'ai oublié de parler
parce que c'est un truc tout nouveau
j'avais complètement zappé c'est une
nouvelle façon d'apprendre à jouer à
magic on a encore charles qui veulent
suite ok bon en attendant marie amélie
quand je mélangeais ça vous fait à la
carte vous pouvez jouer ça a coupé un
tout petit bout c'était comment c'est à
dire une nouvelle manière de jouer à
magic et puis après tu as perdu
je suis désolé c'est la connexion ne pas
être hyper stable ouais je disais du
coup les buzzer jump start fait un truc
nouveau ou en fait vous ouvrez 2 prenez
chaque chaque joueur prend deux buteurs
james startt ils font vainqueurs chacun
voulais mélanger ensemble sans trop
regarder c'est plus rigolo et ça vous
fait des queues de 40 cartes et vous
pouvez jouer l'un contre l'autre avec ça
il en fait tous les boosters jump start
i long terme ça peut des gobelins ça
peut être des humains des elfes des
machins des sorts et c'est assez sympa
apparemment donc aura su bonne chose
n'hésitez pas à tester sa machine
si vous êtes débutant même pas que vous
voulez jouer pendant contre emilie me
m'assassine est ce que tu peux expliquer
ce que c'est qu'une draft battles et
donc l'argent draft
c'est un format conseil de savoir déjà
joué à magic avant d'aller dans une
boutique faire un draft parce que c'est
pas évident et si vous avez besoin de
lire toutes les cartes ça va être assez
compliqué
de nos jours on peut drafté sur magic
arena c'est assez pratique parce qu'on
peut drafté avec des ordinateurs et du
coup on a tout le temps qu'on veut pour
lire les cartes
personne ne nous attend mais le principe
c'est qu'en gros on va ouvrir des
boosters de quinze cartes et en fait on
va être huit autour de la table et
chaque tour chaque douster on va prendre
une carte puis on va le passé à 3,1 et
pas mal de jeu c'était qu'il fonctionne
avec ce système là
et du coup au fur et à mesure par
exemple si au début je voulais une très
bonne carte rouge
j'ai envie de la prendre et peut-être
après je vais avoir dans monster joueurs
plus envie de prendre un carton rouge
parce que je vais avoir envie d'aller
afin d'avoir un deck rouge voire jumeaux
bonnes cartes etc
et du coup à la fin on a toujours avec
différents puisque ben l'aléatoire fait
qu'on a jamais les mêmes cartes et du
coup ça c'est sympa comme de jeu et s'en
remet aux deux genoux il ya pas de
prérequis sur combien d'argent vous
payez et c'est pour votre deck on dit
est ce que vous n'avez joué car et
emilio tech monochrome balle en fait le
principe de ce soir ce soir serment de
la découverte
et puis en plus nous on était deux ans
on était un petit peu rouillé et puis 2
2 c'était sympa de de se chauffer un peu
avec des prêts construit et comme on
parle de 2021
je vais utiliser un deck préconstruits
2021 avec
l'arpenteur tfaily qui ressemble à idris
elba quand je la regrette j'appellerais
idriss si ça vous dérange pas mais je
pense que tout le monde sera d'accord
avec l'inspiration on va écrire et c'est
le magicien du temps ça fait très
longtemps qu'il existe mais là il a
fallu longtemps avant de devenir un
plein soit le coeur c'est un simple
sorcier au début mon histoire est assez
cool il ya pas mal des personnages de
magic où ils ont une histoire assez
profonde il ya des bouquins de tuer toi
aussi je suppose et que ce sera un des
personnages donc la bonne manière pour
découvrir un peu le background derrière
magic enfin l'univers derrière magic
c'est de quoi de lire des livres
il ya des livres ils sont pas tous aussi
bons les uns que les autres
on peut faire gaffe parce qu'un pays
change d'auteur régulièrement et y en a
on d'ivoire à tulle allait super bien et
d'autre on dirait de celui-là lé nul
donc j'ai eu beaucoup de retours mitigés
sur les bouquins mais en tout cas il
raconte l'histoire du de l'univers de
magic des différents personnages et ses
reins ne se sent pas quand vous vous
intéressez à genre de chose en termes de
couleurs toi qui est si l'on trouve
intéressant de jouer avec les éditions
actuelle moi je fais un grand amateur de
deux verres de noir et de bleu j'ai pas
trop le rouge et le blanc et parce que
envoie le j'aime bien le fait que en
vert on a des cartes qui sont assez
efficiente et à des créatures qui sont
grosses pour pas trop cher et maintenant
je peux piocher un peu les cartes aux
siens j'aime bien plus chez descartes
manière générale à magic et c'est un
truc qu'on fait plus dans ces trois
couleurs là que dans les autres de votre
en fait d'ailleurs vous pourrez
remarquer si cet inventif calé trois
cartes que j'ai choisi pour la suite
sont des cartes vertes bleues et noires
après cette partie on fera une toute
petite pose justement pour expliquer le
concept de saison et notamment celle de
cette année qui était
dix corps à corps ya rien hickory voilà
carrière pouvait me rater je me suis
raté donc les bms donc les écailles
jouent les gros monstre justement donc à
charge qui disait que c'était très très
plaisant d'avoir ces grosses créatures
puissantes qui est qui roule sur un peu
tout nantes a choisi trois cartes et
donc tu nous expliquera pourquoi ces
trois cartes de cette saison sont sympas
là j'ai déjà posé donc une île et je
joue un éphémère qui qui s'appelle
option et qui a en action un regard un
donc je vais regarder la carte du dessus
de ma bibliothèque je peux la mettre au
dessous de ma bibliothèque
le floch une carte ça donc je peux pas
piocher celle là ici tu peux l'appeler
fier mais si elle te plait pas je suis
intelligente et la mettre en route hier
très bien donc je la mets dessous voilà
elle te plaît pas la première ne me
plaisait pas oui je ne peux pas dire
comme ça pourquoi pas ce que ça
donnerait des indications omar amélie
bien entendu ce genre de carte par
exemple est très pratique pas ce qui
vous permet d'être des mitigé en fait
l'aléatoire qui fait que vous aurez soit
bon de la rando pas loin de le rendre on
leur dirait bien de piocher un grosse
pelle ou un petit c'est assez pratique
là la sélection là la couleur bleue est
en général les jeux où il ya le plus de
sorts c'est elle qui à une époque quoi
c'est toujours le cas les vieux qui qui
essaie de se remettre à jour a donc là
j'ai deux terrains et donc je vais
pouvoir invoquer à une doyenne g sky qui
a comme capacités c'est une 1 2 qui a
comme capacité la prouesse à chaque fois
que je lance un sort non créatures
chaque créature gagne plus un plus un
jusqu'à la fin du tour s'est elle-même
cette crèche est tellement non merci
effectivement plus d'une jolie de loin
et à chaque fois que la doyenne inflige
des blessures de combat un joueur vous
pouvez piocher une carte
si vous faites ainsi des fossés ou d'une
carte donc ça peut être intéressant si
j'ai plein de carte qui coûte trop cher
et que j'essaye d'avoir un terrain de
quelque chose comme ça par exemple en
fait de manière générale ça va toujours
être intéressant parce qu'au pire si la
carte que tu plonges éléments bien que
toutes celles que tu en as tu le jettes
et si elle est mieux que n'importe
quelle autre carte quand avait en main
était l'amant yard effectivement et donc
fin à part dans le cas où tu à pékin
mais qui finit en me disant encouragé
par dessus mais tant qu'on fait que des
choses simples tu as joué in de m elle a
dit j'ai un saint
oui la tête de langage peut attaquer est
bloqué dans un même tour ce qui est
plutôt cool surtout quand on passe une
créature plus petit c'est le cas tant
qu'ils jouent pas de sorman création
c'est ça bat donc j'espère qu'elle
conventionnement ça pourrait me faire
piocher une carte de plats ça pourrait
être un bluff ça pourrait ne pas être un
bluff faut savoir si à lui faire
confiance ou pas c'est là que s'il a
rien il apte à garder ben si tu vois pas
et si la clause est une loi qui va
manger ta créatures envie de laisser
piocher à tout hasard je bloque hockey
et ben ce n'était pas si c'était
peut-être un bluff c'était à cette étude
c'était du bate parce que du coup je
mets un âne
autant pour moi j'ai mal un schéma lui
jeter comme les olé je pensais que
c'était un éphémère bluff du rituel
parce que les artefacts c'est pas des
effets meyrin absolument saucisson le
flash flash est en effet qui peut se
retrouver sur n'importe quel type de
carte qui donne la faculté de la joue à
tout moment on pourra jouer un effet
mais il ya dynastique qui nous dit alors
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont bêtes est ce que
le figaro stream souvent du magic
c'est la première fois voilà il ya pas
de réponse y'a pas de questions bêtes ou
presque
et donc c'est la première fois et ça se
sent un peu dans on est très contents
que charge soit avec nous parce que on
est pas encore on n'est pas encore apte
allait se lancer dans la vraie arènes de
modiques là où on est un peu rouillé au
dos qui seraient contents parvenir ans
en arrière parce que j'avais mal lu le
truc que je voulais faire de la question
il faut la poser à mariam énigmes
autorise donc en fait avant d'attaquer
je lui jeu l'équipe d'un artefact et qui
lui donne plus sain plus 2 et qui
rajoute en plus à chaque fois que je
pioche une deuxième carte
à mon tour je la tâche à une créature
donc je peux le changer de créature qui
possède cet artefact parce que là il est
associé à cette créature mais si je
pioche si j'ai une autre créature plus
intéressante que là c'est une 1/2 donc
une 2,4 maintenant mais ça pourrait être
plus intéressant de la mettre sur une
créature plus puissante qui risquerait
moins de mourir je suis pas tout à fait
sûr toutes les cartes que tu as en main
valentin avec l'angle de caméra que j'ai
mais ici c'est bien ce que je pense
ouais tu avais un tu avais un truc un
peu sweet que tu pouvais faire situe le
bien cadres ayant tu dis bien
attentivement tous les gars tu peux
faire un truc un peu style est différent
parce que tu as fait mais le scellage
compte elle a joué à la fin ouais mais
en gros ton art est factice équipe tout
seul sans qu'ils aient besoin de payer
site à piocher une deuxième paire dans
le même temps il faut que déjà piocher
une carte à tafas à tafas de pioche il
faut pas qu'il soit déjà sur le terrain
pour que ie6 il faut que tu as déjà sur
le terrain mais il peut s'équiper mais
la bla bla il est pas équipée dans le
cas présent il est pas équipé pour le
jouer et non il faut payer le coût
d'équipement pour l'équipe est ok bah
donc du coup alors je pilote une
deuxième carte
j'utilise l'inventaire effréné qui me
permet de piocher une carte est
potentiellement je pouvais piocher plus
de cartes si j'avais déjà utilisé la
vente à la traîne et donc la prochaine
fois comme je lis comme il est déjà dans
mon cimetière si j'en ai un autre belge
piocherait de cartes ça
l idée c comme c'est un éphémère ton
truc il est boosté temps troqué booster
est un artefact peut s'équiper puisque
tu as vu chez le deuxième cas parfait
effectivement comme si c'était un
éphémère
tu aurais pu le faire au milieu du
combat pour embêter maria mène pour
l'abbaye de st ok bon je vais quand même
être honnête et attaquer et donc ton
truc il ya 1 2 et puis les 4 4,5
c'est pas plus en plus de plus en plus
d'eux et il ya un plus un plus un avec
comme j'ai pioché un autre 3 3 5 dont 3
5 milliards de dépassement
ouais ouais 3,5 moi je crois et du coup
comme je t'ai fait un des gars je peux
piocher une carte lella si je fais ainsi
je vais en défaut c'est une et on va
voir ce que je vais piocher
donc je vais défaut c'est une autre
ok donc je vais des fossés s'est
défaussé donc des fossés jeu des faux
seins anima de grimoire une créature qui
coûte 4 a invoqué 3 3 qui ne qui ne peut
pas être bloqué 6e tour si j'ai pioché
plus plus ou moins de deux cartes ce qui
semble être un thème récurrent ton acte
d'après ce qu'on peut voir
ouais c'est un deck très orienté pioche
réfléchit à jeudi fins wepad enlever ton
petit marqueurs sont à pour ex'im a
jusqu'à la fin l'écart de niveau entre
eux ça flou dit petite question pour
charles la pioche hamadi krobou stèle
sur la chanson sur la variance je sais
pas la différence
on peut m'expliquer aussi je veux bien
la variance est un concept mathématiques
qui indique que la probabilité que des
choses arrivent ça c'est dur à expliquer
comme ça mais en gros il ya une part de
chance et une part de variance à magic
et cd concept un peu complexe sur lequel
vous pouvez lire sur internet si vous
voulez ça c'est dur à expliquer comme ça
m'est donc pour la réponse de pour sa
flou les deux mon capitaine c'est ça
ouais satio dans le cas présent c'est ma
copine donc à dix après m'embêtait ska
avec un complexe où elle sait que je
vais avoir du je vais avoir du mal à
répondre parce que ça les embête
beaucoup quand on joue ensemble laquelle
n'a pas de chance et que je lui dis que
la cause de la faïence d'accord donc
j'invoque un historien de desalle firent
qui est une 3,3 un an voir mon jeu 6-1
2-3 xigua qui à chaque fois qu'il
attaque si je contrôle
mon ami idris elba je pioche une carte
en plus quand il attaque et donc comme
j'ai toujours ma 2,4 je t'attaque parce
que je risque pas grand-chose souci bien
un boost a donc ça veut dire que tu as
un boost et du coup de boost avec un
cycle de croissance pour lui mettre plus
trop plus trash que la fin du tour aux
quais et bassin naturel
par contre ton équipement il va pas
mourir il va rester sur le terrain c'est
comme terminée petula jetons et paix
continue donc dès que je pioche une
autre carte oui je vais ramasser mois à
l'as tu vois par exemple tu as joué sa
créature avant l'attaqué et du coup
marie amélie elle savait qu'ils
pourraient plus rien faire et tout élan
était engagé plus de mal à je suis
mauvais en bluff et du coup peut-être
que dans le cas présent tu aurais pu
jouer sa créature après avoir taillé et
bien fait avoir
j'étais eu
j'attaque annonce aussi que j'attaque
donc là c'est moi qui me posent la
question de s que marie amélie bluff et
si je la bloque
avec mon historien est ce qu'elle va me
faire quelque chose donc je vais perdre
de points de vie en me disant faso situe
la booste quand je laisse passer la taxe
que je ne bloque pas non je vous pas
voilà de m
ok ok
et les artefacts on peut les détruire
comment regarder les causes exactes
ouais c'est ça l'esprit valeur de
taxi-be générale on peut dire un package
des artefacts et enchantement mais je
suis inquiète et couleur marron avant
c'est ça qui maintenant sont gris donc
je vais utiliser la carte que je viens
de piocher une option celle que j'ai
déjà joué au début qui me fait un regard
d'un donc je vais regarder la première
carte soit la garder soit la mettre sous
mac sous ma pioche et piocher une carte
donc ok très bien je la garde l'option
du coup et consommer ce qui me permet
d'attacher le manteau démarré parce qu'à
chaque fois que pioche une deuxième
carte à mon tour je peux la tâche est
une créature donc la tâche
hamon historiens qui maintenant quelles
synergies devient une 4,5
il résistera un peu mieux à une des des
créatures de de marie amélie et je vais
attaquer du coup en me disant qu'elle a
peut-être plus de boost
j'ai black tu bloques chasser mauvaise
témoin things vous peut-être qu'elle
sacrifie un peu peut-être un effet je
suis mais un plus puisque +4 plus
qu'être +4 +4 et alors on en revenait
tout à l'heure à la variance ou pas non
c'est la chance
soyons soyons tout à fait honnête à un
moment il faut appeler un chat un chat
c'est la chance donc ce que je vais
faire c'est que du coup c'est je meurs
aujourd'hui revient ici c'est un peu
récurrent ce que je vais faire c'est que
j'ai par contre ça me permet de finir
mon tour en payant moins cher pour
invoquer une entité et l'orage donc qui
à la base coût de 5
mais je peux l'invoquer pour trois de
moins donc juste deux noms aussi ça si
c'est bien ça hein parce que j'ai joué
un éphémère ce tour ci
donc c'est une vol 3 3 prouesse donc à
chaque fois que je lance un sort non
créatures cette créature gagne plus un
plus un jusqu'à la fin du tour quand
arrive sur le champ de bataille regard 2
donc ça veut dire que je peux piocher de
cartes dans ce papier je les regarde
regarde et de cartes et en garder une ou
plus chez une autre carte et sur leur
est attaché je monte de la marine on est
d'accord ce n'est pas non regardez
simplement tu regardes les deux cartes
et parmi les deux soit tu peux laisser
les deux au dessus soit une des deux au
dessus et en dessous soit les deux en
dessous mais ça ne s'est pas piocher
c'était la deuxième ligne deux options
qui peut piocher
ok donc bah j'en mets une en dessous up
mais je peux du coup quand même attaché
l'artaud fac ce qui m'a fait piocher
notre carte
il n'a pas fait plus gênant c'est ma
deuxième donc je peux pas c'est là
c'était une troisième ok et en plus il
n'a il ne fait pas piocher une autre
carte n'est pas marqué car tu vois là
j'avais tellement la pioche en tête il
fait beau il fait pour sa diction un
arbitre idée je veux piocher et donc je
vous jure je vais allumer à venir chez
moi qui commence à faire sombre je vais
peut-être mais ceci donc tu as une 3 3
vols et ben
j'attaque et j'attaque à la papa donc là
cédé 2,2 potentiellement je peux en tuer
une et je vais miser sur le fait que je
peux la cheville ouais bah je vais
bloqué jambles aucune et ben du coup je
bouge parce que j'aime bien moustiques
donc on en revient sur la chance à la
troisième fois qu'elle a + 4 + 4 gérer
dans tout l'est dans tous les trucs
voici je tiens juste à dire voilà après
tu as un effet avant les gains mois est
pas obligé de laisser la créature mort
tu peux avoir un effet avant les dégâts
potentiellement une fois que sa créature
et bouge à cette fin une 6,6 oui oui 6
non ça je pourrais booster en 4 4 ça
suffirait pas mais par contre c'est la
fin tu finis ton tour ok
vous avez perdu l'état perdu les deux
points de vue j'attendais de savoir si
elle booster pour sarah si on perdait
plus que deux hawk est donc juste avant
la fin de ton tour je joue un inventaire
effréné qui fait piocher une carte puis
un nombre de cartes égal comme j'en
avais déjà joueurs gens proches d'eux
disons qu'à ou alors je sais que
j'aurais pu le garder après pour le
manteau démarrer mais si je veux
invoquer des créatures je vais avoir
besoin de malin surtout ce que tu
n'avais pas vu c'est que tu aurais pu
équiper 30 au démarré pendant les blocs
puisque c'était que chez deux cartes ah
mais ça n'aurait pas suffi ça n'aurait
pas suffi mais qui aurait fait une 4,5
et 5,5 pour la gloire une 5,6 avec la
presse mais bon ça ne suffisait pas à
5,6 à la statue est pas la créature
malheureusement parce que c'était une
6,6 malheureusement hockey et donc c'est
mon tour entre deux on dit est ce qui
incite pour trouver des joueurs près de
chez soi et sinon comment peut-on faire
bon peut en général trouver des
boutiques près de chez soi
il a un site avant que des pétards
wizard mais qui marche pas très bien
souvent le plus efficace et les
complices bouquin c'est pas forcément le
truc le plus chouette mais c'est la
méthode non vous trouverez pas mal de
joueurs sur internet il ya différents
discorde de gens qui jouent à magic
pouvez vous organisez dessus il y avait
des forums donc j'invoque une danseuse
deux vagues de thé ferry
qui a flash et qui surtout à quand la
lanceuse arrive en jeu je peux chercher
dans ma bibliothèque ou dans mon
cimetière mon ami idris elba et le
prendre en main ce qui au passage me
fais piocher une deuxième carte et donc
je peut attacher le manteau démarré
alors heureusement sa cinquième pas
comme ça ça fonctionne pas comme ça
quand tu quand tu mets une carte dans ta
main ce n'est pas qu'on cache ok donc je
le cache pas c'est quoi flèche pardon
lâche juste ça veut dire que tu voulais
jouer n'importe quand comme un éphémère
ça veut dire que dans le cas présent il
aurait pu attendre que tu attaques avec
les deux jours la jouer en flèche avant
les blocs est bloqué mais sympa comme
depuis tout à l'heure tu as des bourses
à chaque fois je l'aurais probablement
encore perdu sa créature voilà donc je
récupère mon ami tu es ferry et je
mélange mon dec parce que j'ai vu les
cartes qu'à l'arrivée en général tout
les cas tous les effets qui demande de
chercher dans ton des grondements des
mélanges et après logique c'est bien
fait pour éviter que les gens trichent
ouais et du coup je dis fin il se passe
quoi si on triche en tournoi magic on
est disqualifié après on peut être
bannis plus ou moins longtemps
un joueur professionnel qui a été pris
en trichant récemment dans un gros
tournoi il a été banni pendant deux ans
plus retiré le titre de hall of fame le
truc plus pauvres c'était un peu la
déshonneur sur lui sa famille ses
ancêtres sap h
rip la vache
je vais jouer une morsure engagés pour
faire 4 dégâts sur ça ok c'est vraiment
nul
c'est un peu le risque que tu as vu de
jouer est un carton face principale
puisque vu que la mort sion en rage est
un rituel elle n'aurait pas pu le faire
au milieu du moins du coup si tu avais
profité de la capacité flash tour a pu
bloquer avec effectivement j'aurais pu
bloquer une dune des créatures ok je me
meurs par bêtise bas de la bêtise va
évidente
8 je prends très cher est ce que ton ami
thierry vas pouvoir te sortir de la
mouise
je pense pas mais on verra attends je
réfléchis invasive
je pense qu'il ne sera pas suffisant oui
ouais donc là j'ai linverse de tout à
l'heure où j'avais passé de manas coup
si j'en ai presque un peu trop
1 2 3 4 5 6 donc je mets mon ami tu es
ferry qui arrive avec 4 un marqueur en
jeu je lui en rajoute un avec son action
qui est piocher une carte
voilà il me restait à mana et j'ai
pioché une carte pour y donc autant dire
que je vais mourir
j'espère vraiment ce n'est pas très
forte ce soir si je me permets tu es en
train de te plaindre de la variance et
j'ai identifié le fait que tu n'as pas
pris la bonne décision
c'est un comportement pas très très bien
magic c'est vrai c'est vrai je blâme les
mathématiques alors que c'est moi mais y
est quand tu quand tu cours soit d'aidés
pour les joueurs de premier rôle et que
ces bêtes là là dans le cas présent tu
ajoutes ferries etc avaient joué ton
autre carte avec une séquence qui était
très forte
tu n'as pas vu malheureusement mais qui
était vraiment bien je pourrais te la
dira prête cette chose là dessus qu'on
leur fait si vous voulez aller besoin de
jouer la montée avant la présente non
mais à ce tour là on fait de la tulle
attaque et les meurtres rien faire et du
coup virton il avec un malin messieurs
le au lieu de jouer ton café riz voilà
tu joues ton autre carte donc le
sourcier des épaves salle humain
vodka 500 qui tresse de malin ouais et
sorciers des épaves quand ils arrivent
en jeu il permet de récupérer un rituel
en effet mais quand on s'y tient enfin
oui donc tu peux récupérer le truc de
l'inventaire le l'inventeur effréné ok
donc je jouais du coup tu non tu le
joues pas tu le gardes pour quand marie
amélie tu attaque s'est rapproché de
carte permettra d'équiper ton manteau et
du coup tu auras un superbe bloqueurs ok
ok bon comme tu sais pas que j'ai posté
j'ai coché un double ou ste plus 30
pouces 30
votez pas dans une super position mais
si elle a un peu n'importe quoi tu es à
peu près mort mais était pas mort
complètement quand même effectivement
j'ai en plus comme elle sept comme elle
sait que tu as à l'épaule eurent attaqué
avec to see mais du coup je bloque la 4
4 ouais je joue l'inventaire effréné qui
me fait piocher deux cas seulement parce
que j'en ai une dans le cimetière parce
que l'autre gelé repris dans ma main et
comme j'ai pioché une carte je peux
effectivement le m elle devient une 4,5
donc elle ne meurt pas contre celui là
s'il pleut ça n'ira pas au bout cela la
prouesse en place oui faut l'avouer
three calais 5 6
ah oui les 5-6 hockey et je suis à deux
points de vie je vais jouer crocodiles
tuent fait des envieux charles il ya un
internaute qui demandent si tu propose
des sessions de coaching magic et je ne
propose pas des sessions de coaching
mais il ya plein de joueurs des joueurs
du magic très forts qui font de stream
régulièrement
vous apprendrez beaucoup on à le
regarder leur stream savez faut
peut-être être plus patient e que ce que
je suis effectivement pour la demande un
peu de patience
qui a donc je pose un autre terrain ok
c'est bien ce que ta piaule ouais je
pense que je vais la jouer
ce sont elles me permettra de faire un
un bloc
donc c'est une vandales ferry qui a
flash vol j'aurais pu la jouer encore
une fois ouais mais dans le cas présent
dans le cas présent il fallait pas je
pense
ok non je la joue à la fllash vol c'est
une 1/2 et à chaque fois que je pioche
une deuxième carte à chaque tour mais tu
es un marqueur plus un plus un sur le
vandale ferry ce qui va être beaucoup
plus facile en fait c'est beaucoup plus
facile pendant ton tour que par le
retour de l'adversaire parce que tu as
une carte de -1 piocher pour ça que
c'est souvent intéressants de la joie
tout à fait et donc comme il me reste
six là je peux appeler idris elba tu
peux mais est ce que c'est ce que tu as
envie de faire ah non tu as raison tu as
raison je vais m
je vais mettre une rafale de vent
je mets une rafale de vent sur ton
crocodile signifie quoi le remonter dans
maman ou un truc comme ça ça que deux
exactement à dépenser parce que j'ai une
créature call vol il revient dans ta
main et il me fait piocher une carte ce
qui fait que la vandales devient 2,3 et
que tu peux rééquiper ton manteau si tu
en as envie que je peux rééquiper le
manteau
ah c'est pas mal et du coup comme j'ai
pioché une créature je paye 3 de mana et
je mets ce poisson l'exo cerfs volants
mystique qui à chaque fois que je pioche
ma deuxième carte à chaque tour ça lui
donne le vol donc voilà et c'est une 3 3
2 dans mes bras et et
4 3 e non parce que là je sais j'ai
lancé un sort donc à la plus simple est
mis la perche 4 1 du tout donc c'est
jusqu'à la fin du tour ouais donc dès
que moi je dirais fin ça sera ton tour à
toi donc que ce qui est déjà pas mal
elle avait deux petits dés de là tu vois
tu vois que tu es en train de stabiliser
cette position alors que tout à l'heure
je te plaignais ne pas avoir de chance
c'est sa très belle a longtemps que
j'avais en fait juste pas de talent
merci de me le rappeler c'est comme si
ma mère me le disait pas assez souvent
je suis désolé c'est en jeu non j'ai
juste joué un peu bourrin parce que j'ai
croisés chrétiens plein ou volcker un
plein
walker texas ranger on dit qu'il ya des
questions sur premiers rôles je pense
que on pourra y répondre tout à la fin
tout à la fin ça fait pour augmenter
notre einstein notre porte
durée de visionnage il paraît que c'est
bien donc restez connectés par des infos
sur premiers rôles que tu n'as pas qu
pas ok c'est vrai que j'ai que deux
comme à la cape créatures il suffit
qu'elle en est une qui passe au prochain
tour pour que je meurs donc vous voyez
qu'il reste à peu près 10 boost en main
ça va pas être un problème
ça va dépendre de ce que je vais piocher
qui donc j'aurai puis j'aurais dû bluffé
par montrer que j'ai pioché une île donc
je pose mon ami idris elba j'ai pas
grand chose d'autre à faire c'est quand
même pas mal
ce qui est quand même pas mal ça qui va
me permettre de piocher une carte et je
vais espérer que ce soit une créature
une créature qui coûtent pas le cacher a
invoqué tu peux lire les faits complet
de la carte
peut-être que
tu auras envie de faire autre chose si
tu te rends compte de tout ce qu'il fait
j'aime bien choc qui secoue le cerveau
de valentin on voit les petits neurones
qui s'activent
il a quatre donc je peux soit piocher
une carte soit mettre une créature
ciblés au dessus de la bibliothèque de
son propriétaire ce qui bloquerait un
marais amis à 3 ce tour si effectivement
elle serait obligée de la secal piochera
ça ah si j'ai d'autres créatures
quand marie amélie attaque elle peut le
ciblées absolument quand elle attaque
elle choisira chacun sait chaque
créature si elle tâte acte waouh c'est
l'attaqué fait je peux pas le défendre
le blog c'est seulement pour moi si tu
peux bloquer comme tu veux mais du coup
tu devras bloquer les créatures qui
s'attaquent soit et série soit toi tu as
raison je vais faire ça je pars raison
j'étais juste dit de lire ta carte merci
je je vais tenter ça je regretterais
peut-être mais du coup le crocodile
machin revient en haut de la pile mais
quelle surprise que vais-je donc cacher
et je vais dire fin qui est
il ya une petite question entre 2
combien de temps faut-il pour assimiler
les bases du jeu et bien le temps d'un
live filière volaille et sans plus
amplement c'est difficile de définir ce
que sont les bases du jeu parce qu il ya
vraiment beaucoup de règles et au fur et
à mesure qu'on apprend à jouer on se
rend compte que la barre de savoir jouer
et monte je pense que là à la fin du
rêve des gens corrompus suivi ils
sauront prendre en main c'est d'être là
et jouer avec sans trop de problèmes
voilà j'ai surtout quand on me regarde
jouer on peut bien distinguer le savoir
jouer et le savoir bien jouer
ce qui est important ça fait partie des
choses que je trouve très sympa non on
connaît les règles vous beaucoup de
temps à savoir jouer bien c'est
quasiment infinie un peu les cartes en
main j'ai plus qu'à reprendre un j'ai
plus de quoi jouer bourrin
je suis arrivé à deux donc il faut pas
grand chose pour que ça passe oui je
suis à 2
donc je vais piocher ah ouais je vais
piocher une carte parce que je peux pas
faire son action à moins 3 donc il passe
à 2 je pioche une carte le fait de
piocher une carte boost
ma créatures qui volent et celle-là
acquiert le vol bon ça sert à quelque
chose
mais par contre le qatar qui aiment la
pioche et si on attaquait une créature 5
qui est le sourcier des épaves qui a
prouesse les mêmes catalans qui elle
même que tout à l'heure
et quand le sourcier des épaves arrive
sur le champ de bataille renvoyer une
carte d'éphémères ou de rituels ciblés
depuis votre cimetière dans votre main
donc je vais prendre l'inventaire
effréné camaro déjà je sais pas ouais je
pense que c'est celui qui sera le plus
pratique pour moi
voilà en quoi y avait longtemps qu'ils
jouent et là stupeur un truc qui donne
plus disposée cpt banking west à la
casse et du coup est ce que je le joue
maintenant
où est ce que je le joue pendant autour
de marie amélie il faut que tu pèse le
pour et 1 contre
j'ai déjà répondu à beaucoup de
questions pas répondu à ce qu'il faut
faire
bon je vais le jouer maintenant parce
que je suis joueur d'accord non s'ils
saluent pression la pression si je le
joue maintenant parce que si je peux
chine quelque chose d'intéressant
donc là je vais pouvoir piocher deux
cartes parce que une pour le premier et
à gênés par exemple les rennais 1 déjà
dans mon cimetière qui pèse quelque
chose d'intéressant tu pourras jouer
avec tout émane a engagé saison et ce
qui tombe bien c'est que je pioche une
autre créature je vais le jouer tout de
suite hein et sert le petit poisson
l'exaucer voulons mystique et là je dis
fin
en fait l'avantagent ou que tu avais
avant d'évaluer pendant ton tour c'était
qui permettait de déclencher d'affairé
puisque tu aurais pioche est d'auto de
cartes mon tour de marie amélie est
aussi tu pouvais areata chez tonton
artefacts sur une autre créature si ça
pouvait être soutien mais non parce que
là on va le faire ici et la deuxième
carte pendant mon tour
oui m non c'est pendant un tour ok mais
du coup ça fait une sauvegarde se fera
pas deux et non pas ce qui a pu appeler
chez deux cartes truc de l'inventaire
mais oui ah bah oui bah voila c'est
parce que je suis encore une fois je le
rappelle et ma mère aussi pas mal hein
et c'est le stress du live
les blagues de julien l'ars mais sa
force de faire désirer sa peur de faire
des erreurs faut pas se mettre trop de
pression tout à fait marie amélie a dû
piocher une créature
donc je n'attaque pas et la pioche en
effet que tu le dis plus rapidement je
sais pas si je t'aime pas oui si tu as
le piétinement potentiellement tu peux
me tuer selon comment je bloque sa plus
grosse la tête tu as ton tu as une 1,5
ça c'est
c'est ça la plus grosse 5 4 5 4 5 à 4 5
3 1 3 1 e
3 5 et 3 3 3 4 ans dans 3-4
ok j'attaque avec un crocodile qui est
une 3 3 i-vtec j'attaque ce que
j'attaque monsieur je te tais toi moi
dans le cas présent apparemment de
raisons attaque était ferré puisque s'il
prend les points perdus
donc là là si je pars du principe que
marie amélie bluffs je bloque juste avec
le poisson volant qui est une 3 1 et qui
pourrait tuer sa créature mourir mais si
la carte qu'elle a lui donne le
piétinement
c'est ces piétinements qui fait que les
points de dégâts et déborde de la
créature et me touche c'est à dire qu'il
veut mal marche sur le corps sans aucun
respect et je suis sans voix là et
mais si je bloque avec plusieurs cartes
elle répartit les points de dégâts
jusque jusqu'à jusqu'à consulter dernier
en bluffant donc je vais
bloquée avec celle qui est 5 en espérant
qu'elle n'est pas un booster qu'elle est
bluffé alors maintenant ce genre de
situation juste avant lui prêta décision
dans les rallyes dans ce genre de
situation comme tu es très très bon
point de vue c'est intéressant de se
prémunir contre tout ce qui pourrait
arriver c'est à dire un excès qui
boosterait de beaucoup et bloque et
donnerait piscine où je pense que j'ai
la situation avait intérêt à bosser à
bloquer avec plusieurs créatures et au
cas où quitte à en perdre une ou deux si
elle a un bon emploi d'une ou deux
j'avais un truc mais après tu as pris ta
décision
j'ai pris ma décision il est temps que
je meurs c'est merci j'ai bien fait mais
content parce que à palper la gagne plus
un plus un jet à la fin du tour pour
chaque créature que je contrôle donc ils
gagnent plus qu'être +4 voilà je t'en
sors bien priori non car je suis une
créature qui tient la route un truc est
là le piétinement pas non à la pac et
hymne parfait
bon j'aurais dû sacrifier l'exode est
mais c'est la vie a de la chance car
profitant
voilà donc j'ai plein de terrain je
pioche une carte ati tenir est de points
de vie hop
j'utilise la capacité de des ferries qui
me fait piocher une carte ce qui passe
ma faille rit encore un boost et eu peur
équipe est aussi attendu je peux
rééquiper en main le manteau démarrer du
coup je vais le mettre sur elle pour
qu'elle soit bien bien costaud là tu
fais ce qu'on appelle mettre tous ses
oeufs dans le même panier
voilà voilà voilà voilà
et fin
la communauté des joueurs de magic c'est
des gens de quel jeu parce que ya des
critères sociaux j'ai pas d'âge de 20 c
c'est principalement des hommes de 25 à
35 ans qui moins un peu d'argent parce
que le jeu est pas et pas à donner en
tous cas d'invitation mais c'est pas
pour autant que c'est des gens
désagréables je trouve que c'est des
gens qui sont en majorité très
intelligent et intéressant et c'est un
vrai plaisir de faire partie de cette
communauté et pas beaucoup de joueuses
dans la communauté
non mais les quelques tournois que j'ai
fait il ya quinze ans je devais tout il
n'a pas beaucoup il y en a de plus en
plus mais on part d'assez longues heures
on part de jeu par delors 84 pour ça
donc forcément même si on monte à 10 % à
15 %
c'est bien mais on n'est pas encore quoi
mais après voilà les gens essayent de
pousser l'inclusivité - y compris bien
sûr pour que n'est pas genre de problème
est qu il ya les mêmes pressions sur le
online
non je pense que sur le online ya plus
de filles justement parce qu'il ya eu
des des comportements un peu
communautaire s qui ont poussé les
filles en dehors des boutiques que t'as
pas trop en ligne versements et du cou
quatre jeudis fin chef qui l'attaquent
tu pars dont l'historien de la vire à
chaque fois qu'il attaque si je contrôle
mon ami idris elba je pioche une carte
donc je viens ainsi en fond tu peux nous
mettre un petit à will survive
ça pourrait me booster cherche alors
commencé à attaquer un genre oui c'est
ça c'est un peu ce que je commence à me
dire vu que son nombre de deux créatures
dépasse le mien je pense avoir un petit
peu chaud je mets une saison de
croissance qui me permet de d'avoir
regard enfin ta capacité de la même
capacité que tu utilises depuis tout à
l'heure
voilà à chaque fois que je jouais une
créature puis c'est tout ok elle est à
chaque fois que tu bosses c'est une
créature du clash aussi oui absolument
tout à fait c'est pas mal quand même on
a vu tu avais pas mal de beau temps
tomber we hope
je joue un terrain je te renvois
non je vais piocher une carte pardon
s'il refusait de refuser une garde quand
on peut piocher ce qui le boost
grandement à tu as pris ta carte en main
dès qu'on la voit pas ah pardon je vais
quand même le poser c'est un autre
manteau démarrer donc l'artefact qui
pour l'instant n'est pas équipé qui est
le même qui est déjà posée et si je
pioche une une autre carte
j'aurais pourtant j'aurai des effets
donc tu as 5 1 2 3 4
je sais tu auras non je sais pas ce que
tu auras parce que gérait renvoyé dans
ta main sur mon mec tu renvoies dans les
coups sur le des coups sur la main quand
tu renvoies avec qui ça dépend des sorts
celui là c'est sur la question grecque
donc là j'ai cinq créatures dont
plusieurs qu'on le vol donc je vais
utiliser une petite 3 1
pour attaquer marc emilie avec le vol en
face on a là qu'un point de vie donc sur
la protection du piétinement ça sera pas
bézef voilà je prends là par exemple ce
que tu auras peut faire comme tu as
beaucoup de mal à t'aurais pu équiper la
créature avec laquelle tu aller attaquer
avec tout et mentaux et ensuite ré
équiper les autres créatures avec 4 à
les défendre avec des manteaux et oui à
tout le monde parce que à trop de choses
à faire
j'étais resté sur le il faut que je
pioche une deuxième pour l'équipe est
passé chers mais le tableau de manet
maintenant tu peux te le permettre en
fait tout à fait vrai et ben voilà c'est
tout je sens que cette partie m donc un
temps à la femme
ben non je vous tiens d'intérêt à
l'équipe et maintenant mais si je peux
les inscrits on mangeait mal et je paye
pour l'équipe et je vais l'équipe et sur
l'historien comme ça aminata qui
survivra il me fera
piocher une carte même s'il meurt tout
façon il pourra piocher une carte c'est
quand il défend quand il attaque le cher
et si tu défends mon homme
combien tu as dit il trop soit soyons
tout à fait honnête trop et c'est
peut-être pour ça que que ça équilibre a
pas trop en a jamais trop de terre on a
juste assez des cours jusqu'à voter tous
les terrains
je vais rajouter à me faire un marqueur
sur idriss ce qui booste mon poisson
volant énormément il me fait piocher une
carte supplémentaire
ce n'est pas un poisson
une féerie alors je me pose une question
vous qui voyez mon dec
je pense que je ne vais pas jouer cette
carte maintenant par contre marie amélie
a toujours entre guimaëc quatre cartes
pour pour défendre pour pour défendre
donc je vais
[Musique]
je vais attaquer avec l'historien comme
ça il me fera piocher et si elle a un
boost elle sera obligée de le consommer
ou de sacrifier une de ces créatures
voilà je tente le temps il veut pas ton
truc c'est ça non ils veulent pas tu
peux bloquer avec lui mais par contre là
comme je viens de dire que ge a pas que
je peux piocher
absolument j'ai pas vu t'as déjà activé
dans plein de soldats ont par contre oui
j'ai déjà fait le pioche d'accord du
coup ce n'est pas la deuxième carte que
je sache la tour c c'est la troisième
parce que du coup ton un peu fac ne se
déclenche pas ouais enfin je l'avais
déjà attaché je l'avais déjà tâche est
rude bataille d'alger cuve à l'autre il
est 4 5 7 5
oui tu peux bloquer avec 2 je veux tu
restes
mais c'est moi qui le real et wau avec
oui mais
bon ça dépend du poète y prendre les
points mais le problème c'est que c'est
durant les points il va pouvoir
réattaquer au prochain tour et à chaque
tour et je vais je vais couper un
crocodile est une sentinelle pour
bloquer hockey du coup je tue le
crocodile ce qui est plus intéressant
pour pour moi et je vais tricher comme
un gros porc parce qu'en fait je vais
décalé l'autre manteau en payant 3 et ce
qui lui fait la fête c'est quand tu vas
ça par contre je peux tu ne peux pas
déclasser le manteau quand tu veux aller
d'équipement est une qui reste et qui
peut faire peur mais une fessée
spécifiant bas du texte
il ya beaucoup ok bon bah du pardon tu
peux aller un millime heures un autre
truc tu peux faire un autre truc dans la
médaille pas content avec ce côté mais
ouais ouais non tout à fait à temps j'ai
autre chose à faire c'est d'abord le
même monsieur je vais